[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous ont habité de
5 à 10 ce matin miguel laventure bon
jour pour jour vous êtes le secrétaire
général des forces martiniquaises de
progrès une fois n'est pas coutume mais
quelle aventure dans cette émission je
propose d'écouter serge letchimy lors du
congrès du parti progressiste
martiniquais dimanche dernier il a parlé
de vous écouter il n'a jamais cessé
d'être
comme il est en train de s'approprier le
cheminement des autres il est extrait et
copier coller un mot gentil la bouche
c'est le désert est sorti de ma bouche
le croire la différenciation n'est pas
la nuit du droit à l'égalité alors mais
quelle aventure vous êtes pickpockets
vous leur d'idées de concepts de mots de
mots de mots différenciation écoutez
vous avez choisi de démarrer cette
émission sur une publicité que vous
faites a comme politique et ben ça c'est
votre responsabilité quant à celui que
vous nous faites écouter il a eu tout le
week-end dernier pour s'exprimer je
souhaite que nous puissions parler de 2
à faire quand vous le voulez bien on
pourra parler de la différenciation qui
devait évidemment la propriété de
personne
nous sommes très clairement dans
l'expression d'une réalité qui a été
inscrite dans la constitution
il est également inscrite dans les
textes européens vous savez que c'est
sur ce fondement lac qu'il y a les
régions ultrapériphériques et vous savez
que tout notre mobilisation aux forces
martiniquaises de progrès tout notre
dynamique de travail et précisément
fondée sur cette combinaison de la
réalité que nous appartenons à des
grands ensembles la france l'europe mais
que nous sommes 5
lle est que cette singularité ses
particularités cette existence propre
doit être en permanence dans notre
esprit et doit attribuer la totalité de
notre réflexion et d'autres actions vous
partager les mêmes visions avec serge
letchimy vous êtes autonomistes vous
aussi alors soyons clairs nous savons
que à la martinique il y a beaucoup de
confusion nous sommes probablement dans
une très forte je dirais différence avec
beaucoup d'autres nous pensons que nous
sommes probablement je ne dis pas les
seuls mais en tout cas plus intensément
que d'autres dans cette conscience
d'être des martiniquais avec des droits
résultant de notre qualité de citoyen
forcé et que à ce titre là nous avons à
faire prospérer tous ceux qui résultent
de 7,2 ce positif de ce positionnement
et je le dis aussi bien au niveau
national qu'au niveau européen et que
cela doit conduire à faire en sorte que
ces droits ne soient jamais mis en cause
que ce soit la différenciation ou que ce
soient les spécificités tout ceci est
fondé sur très simplement le fait que
nous savons que ce que nous pouvons
revendiquer et totalement je dirais
évident ça n'a rien à voir avec le taux
de moby l'autonomie c'est la position
qui conduit à faire en sorte que l'on
doit négocier et par conséquent on peut
avoir un risque que nous droits ne
soient pas respectés ni autonomie ni
indépendance il y as appartenance mais
une appartenance d'originalité une
appartenance de différence une
appartenance de conscience de ce que
nous sommes en propre et c'est cela qui
est l'essence même de ski à four des
forces martiniquaises de progrès il ya
déjà plus 20 ans d'accord sur
l'échiquier de la droite il ya un gars
ya différents diverses divers courants
il ya lieu l air il ya ba pays enchanté
aujourd'hui persona non grata non
dans baby en chance et y aller le modem
et fmp dans tout ce courant la sq il ya
unité de pensée comme la vôtre
est ce que vous vous retrouvez alors je
veux dire chacun a le droit d'avoir son
positionnement sous le rap l'air
l'instant forces martiniquaises de
progrès a été créé il ya plus de 25 ans
nous avons pendant tout ce temps qui
s'est écoulé fait en sorte que chacun
puisse comprendre que c'est je dirais la
perspective impérative pour nous pour la
martinique de faire en sorte que nous
puissions à tout instant et chez ou
toute matière faire valoir que ce que
nos aînés ont obtenu c'est à dire que
nous soyons respectés dans notre qualité
de citoyen français que jamais on ne
puisse venir le remettre en cause
et bien que cela non seulement nous
donne des droits mais nous donne une
force à partir de laquelle nous devons
pouvoir faire en sorte que tout aille
mieux c'est c'est cette manière d'être
qui est essentielle mais elle signifie
aussi que les décisions doivent être
prises localement forces martiniquaises
de progrès qui j'écris d'ailleurs au
pluriel et vous comprenez bien que cela
signifie qu'il peut y avoir des yeux
je dirais une nuance est bien à cette
singularité que toutes nos décisions
toute notre organisation tout notre
dispositif et martiniquais mais nous le
faisons je répète avec une philosophie
qui fait que nous pouvons aujourd'hui
revendiqué toute une série de choses
pour lesquelles il n'y a aucune
interrogation qui puisse exister dans la
tête de ceux avec qui nous parlons je
veux dire les dirigeants français les
dirigeants européens qui pourraient dire
mais il dirige sa mais est ce qu'ils
sont dans cette jeune dire hey positions
de travail de manière durable
prenons un exemple aujourd'hui yagil
entendu dans votre bulle terre il est
question de la préoccupation des
sargasses et bien voilà une matière sur
laquelle nous avons à faire
en sorte que toutes les capacités
nationales toutes les capacités
européennes qui peuvent exister se
mobilisent pour la risle ce je dirais se
décline pour apporter des solutions non
pas parce que nous considérons que ça
serait bien que généreusement ils le
fassent mais c'est parce que c'est une
obligation
ils doivent avoir vis-à-vis de citoyens
qui sont des citoyens qui appartiennent
au niveau national qui appartiennent au
niveau européen et que c'est donc une
exigence pour nous de faire en sorte que
toutes les potentialités toutes les
capacités
toutes les solutions qui sont
envisageables à ce niveau globo qui
évidemment dépasse les seules
potentialités martiniquais tv que tout
cela soit réellement mis en oeuvre et
que ça ne soit pas encore une fois une
chose négociable mais ce soit une chose
qui s'impose et notre notre je dirais
puissance à forces martiniquaises de
progrès c'est de pouvoir aller le dire
n'importe où sans que jamais il y ait
dans la tête d'un interlocuteur la seule
la moindre interrogation la moindre
hésitation parce que nous sommes très
authentiquement des personnes qui
prenant nos responsabilités je répète et
respectant tout ce qui a été fait par
nous aider nous pouvons faire en sorte
que tout cela soit je dirai donnez avec
respect alors des obligations légales
miguel laventure quels sont les calculs
et la stratégie d'edf mp pour ces
municipales ou n'avait qu'une mairie
celle de rivière salée
j'ai cru entendre lors de votre rentrée
que vous aviez dix candidats ce que vous
avez dix a déjà désigné les communes ce
que vous savez déjà
vous allez positionner tout s'est dit
candidat alors n'ai pas le souvenir
d'avoir ni moi même dire que notre
dirigeant donnait un chiffre de
candidats je pense que la position que
nous avons exprimé a été clairement
comprise nous ferons en sorte que pour
chacune des communes les forces
martiniquaises de progrès apporte la
meilleure contribution possible
alors cette contribution peut être de
premier plan conduite d'une liste et
organisation d'un d'une candidature
propre mais cette
contribution peut apparaître sous la
forme de combinaison d'alliances ou la
forme je dirais de regroupement avec
d'autres d'autres partenaires avec
lesquels nous pouvons offrir à la
population une perspective clairement
l'objectif pour nous c'est à travers six
élections municipales d'apporter une
réponse ou trois plans le premier c'est
dans chaque commune
parce que les situations sont variables
d'une commune à l'autre prendre en
compte les difficultés les problèmes les
perspectives aussi et les espérances
pour faire en sorte que on apporte une
solution appropriée et cette solution
elle doit être réfléchie localement
deuxièmement faire en sorte que nous
puissions bien comprendre que la
dynamique qui existe aujourd'hui en
martinique elle bien elle s'organise
dans un contexte qui a été je dirais
marqué à cl fortement pendant ces
dernières années pendant ces dix
dernières années par une diminution de
la population qui est un signal
préoccupant est que vis-à-vis de cela il
ya un sursaut du doigt que l'on doit
avoir
et puis le troisième élément est bien si
la hausse y est
et c'est l'esprit forces martiniquaises
de progrès c'est que nous ne soyons pas
dans une sorte je dirais d'un alignement
par rapport à des décisions qui
pourraient être prises au niveau
parisien mais qui au contraire sorte du
terrain par toutes les possibilités
les offres qui peuvent être inventées
structurée au niveau local candidat fort
de france alors je suis candidat à fort
de france pour pouvoir mettre cette
dynamique en route ça n'avait pas dire
que je suis en train d'annoncer que je
vais conduire une liste là maintenant
qui est déjà prête avec des personnes de
tueur et déjà été identifiées je suis
candidat à faire en sorte qu'il y ait
une polarisation positives globales
vous êtes en train de vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'être la tête de liste je suis
en train de dire qu'aujourd'hui je ne
peux pas être dans ces pratiques
anciennes ou celui ci ou celui là vient
proclamer unilatéralement que les jeux
d'hier est dans une position qui n'est
pas discutable tout est discutable
simplement je dis que j'ai conduit des
listes ça coinçait par conséquent que
j'en ai la capacité je suis conseiller
municipal de fort de france donc chacun
sait que je sais mener campagne et faire
en sorte que nous soyons élus mais nous
ne voulons rien imposer ni brutalité ni
non plus je dirais essayer de tromper
qui que ce soit vous êtes en train de
passer là mais miguel laventure c'est ce
que vous êtes en train de dire que là
maintenant l'heure est venue de que de
former la relève de lisser la relève
reprendre la bataille également je suis
en train de donner la main entendez bien
de donner la main sa vie d'un élève à
qui alors ici sebral je vous remercie
votre question parce que c'était ça que
j'attendais à toutes celles et tous ceux
qui considèrent que aujourd'hui la
situation très dégradée de
fort-de-france très dégradé et bien
appel que chacun se dépassent et que
chacun cherche autour de lui peu importe
le parti ça peut être le palima ça peut
être le modem mais je sais pas pourquoi
vous dites que je souhaitais que ces
deux là il y en a d'autres encore et
marcos et caen donc l'idée c'est de
faire en sorte qu' il y ait suffisamment
je dirais de préoccupation qui aille au
delà des sensibilités individuelles ou
deux parties de chacun pour que
véritablement on est une offre à
fort-de-france qui fasse que eh bien
j'ai fait de se promener dans les rues
mais il suffit de discuter avec la
population pour sentir qu'il ya des
satisfactions et bien pour faire en
sorte que nous puissions donner donner à
fort-de-france donner à l'ensemble de la
population
en fait des représentants choisis
ensemble des opportunités d'une
espérance particulière mais quelle
aventure je vous remercie pas si une
excellente journée à l'écouté de nos
programmes
merci beaucoup
[Musique]